♪ Can you see? ♪
- There are days in every child's life
that change who they are forever.
- (exclaiming)
- This is the extraordinary story...
...of how we learn to talk...
- Ba ba!
-  (both babbling)
- ...think...
- What's that, Mommy?
- It's a doggy.
- Why?
- Why, Daddy?
- ...and love.
- This is your new baby brother.
♪ ...listens ♪
♪ Rising within me ♪
- From the moment we're born,
to when we turn five.
♪ We're flyin' higher ♪
- Wee wee! Five.
- Hello, Mommy. How are you?
♪ We're flying high ♪
♪ It's a good day for dreaming ♪
- The first 2,000 days of life
told through the eyes
of 100 children around the world.
- (in Japanese) Ready, set, go!
- (shouting)
♪ It's a good day for dreaming ♪
♪ There's a hope,
there's a star, there's a fire ♪
♪ There's a light in the dark
where it's brighter ♪
- When I grow up,
I want to be an astronaut.
- Teacher.
♪ It's a good day for dreaming ♪
- Say ma-ma.
- Da-da.
- No! Ma-ma-mummy!